can you imagine usopp becoming one of
the most important characters in the
story fulfilling prophecies acquiring
conquerors hockey and even taking out
one of the yonko no well i can i think
that after whole cake island being
sanji's arc and wano being zoro's arc
albath will be the arc of god usop where
the cowardly insecure and lying boy from
syrup village will become one of the
fiercest and bravest warriors the
endless seas of one piece have ever seen
so put on your best pair of sniper
goggles and allow me to share with you
the gospel of the almighty and all
knowing creator of one piece god usap hi
there my name is manu and usop has
always held a very special place in my
heart out of any fictional character
really today i want to walk you through
his incredible character arc on tilwano
that turned him into one of the most
beloved characters in fiction and then
share a number of carefully selected
exquisite theories with you that might
foreshadow some major developments for
usopp and his powers very soon usab is
an incredibly interesting character in a
multitude of ways take his name for
example usop is a combination of the
famous greek storyteller and fabulist
aesop and the japanese word uso that
literally means lie oda clearly was
fully aware of where he wanted the
character to go because usual is both a
great liar and a fantastic storyteller
and on top of that he is by far the most
quote unquote normal member in a crew of
absolute monsters which made it super
easy for me to relate to his experience
traveling with the straw hats i was
incredibly impressed how well
established these fundamental traits
were at syrup village where we first get
to meet usopp immediately you and i know
that this is someone who craves
attention above anything else he lies
and exaggerates to any and everyone he
meets just to have people notice him
this is literally the story of peter and
the wolf this deceptiveness and
pretentiousness in everything he says
and does made usopp extremely unlikable
to me initially however just a little
later we find out why usopp is basically
an orphan his mother died when he was
still young and his father left him to
become a pirate now to be fair it was
shanks who is fighting for a better
world and i don't think yasub is a bad
person from what i can tell so far but
let's be real he doesn't deserve a
father of the year award for it either
in my eyes this left usop with two
choices resent his father for leaving or
as he did in the end glorifying him for
it after all why would he leave his only
kid behind if he wasn't a legendary
pirate with very important work to do
this really hits home hard when you
realize that it's probably exactly this
insecurity about being left behind that
led to usop's chronic lying in the first
place he lies about being a great and
powerful pirate having had many
adventures just like his father because
he feels like he could never truly be
this person in reality instead he sees
himself as weak insecure and worthless
in arguably his worst sight keep that in
mind for water 7. at the same time
however i love that we also get
introduced to the best in usopp on the
sickbeds of his dying mother and of his
friend kaya he also fabricates stories
[Music]
however while his usual eyes are meant
for getting himself some attention these
stories are meant to brighten up the day
of people he truly cares about it's the
storyteller inside him caring for others
and to me it's exactly this altruism
that is the basis for usopp becoming a
brave warrior of the sea and oh boy if
the theories i have in store for you are
just a little bit true he will be a
great warrior in deeds it's during his
fight with 2 on arlon park that he finds
the stream
but honestly i do believe that usopp is
brave right from the very beginning
usop's cowardice is actually very much
self-imposed effectively it's another
one of his lies and this even links to
the concept of him telling lies that
later become true usop's self-doubt acts
as what is called a self-fulfilling
prophecy even though he's often scared
in the end he always decides to stay
fight and do the right thing he has
shown time and time again that when it
really counts he's undeniably brave
proud and honorable so to me his arc is
not at all about becoming brave because
bravery requires fear to be overcome in
the first place no to me his real arc is
about building confidence accepting
himself and finding a purpose
the next big step in his character arc
is during alabasta and honestly i
couldn't help but be incredibly
impressed how he overcomes his fear to
be heard and once again steps out
against an opponent he thinks is way out
of his league already at this point here
he's willing to give his life for his
captain and declares his loyalty to
luffy interestingly enough however just
a while later we experience usop's
lowest point in the story so far however
i'd argue that his fight with luffy and
his leaving the crew doesn't diminish
his belief that luffy will be pirate
king at all the going mary the ship that
had been given by his village has become
a full member of the crew to the point
where usop could even see a
manifestation of its spirit something
that will be important later on by the
way
conqueror's hockey now this member of
the crew had gotten too weak to fulfill
its purpose and was about to be left
behind by the rest usopp sees himself to
be the next in line despite all the
courage he has already shown he still
has the world's biggest imposter
syndrome it's the very same reason why
he tried to forcibly put himself on a
level with luffy he's struggling to find
a purpose that allows him to stay useful
and stay with the crew
at this point usual is the only one that
doesn't have a fixed role in the crew
yet he isn't recognized at the sniper
yet at this point only during enes lobby
does he come back as sergey king a
representation of everything usopp
thinks he wants to be he hides behind a
mask that allows him to slip into a more
confident persona as a result his
actions on anna's lobby establish him as
the sniper of the crew and after
witnessing the lengths that luffy would
go to to keep a crew member through
robin he finally overcomes his fear of
being left behind and apologizes to
everyone
trilla bark however proves to us how
insecure usopp still is even under the
mask of soggy king all while once again
taking down a strong opponent i was very
positively surprised to see then that
dress rose out of all places was usopp's
biggest moment of character development
yet the tantarada have put all their
hopes into usopp thinking that their
hero usolando will come and help them
the stress for uso in this arc has been
building up steadily and in the end he
just couldn't handle the pressure of the
responsibility he had brought unto
himself with his own lies so he runs
away unfortunately usop represents one
of the main themes of dressrosa here
deception all this time doflamingo had
been deceiving the tontara and usop was
essentially doing the same thing however
in the end their cries finally reach
usopp without sergey king to hide behind
he finally accepts himself as a true and
strong member of the straw hat crew
[Music]
gains confidence in himself and his
capabilities to be a real hero and is
rewarded immensely for it with one of my
favorite moments after the timeskip
[Music]
as a result the usop we see in wano is
the most confident but also most
competent version of him we have ever
seen turning the tides wherever he
appears so now that i want to move on to
usop's future in the story what's
important to know is that usopp keeps
fulfilling many of his major lies one
after another becoming more and more the
hero he aspires and i guess fantasized
as a kid to be as always everything from
here on out is speculation based on my
previous analysis but i'm really excited
about all of these possibilities and as
you probably already suspected elbaf
will be the basis for all of these
theories elbaf spelled backwards after
all is fable and it'll be the most
important arc for our storytelling fable
master yet throughout the story usop has
forged relationships with all the giants
that he's met first on little garden
with dory and bragi that inspire him to
become like the giant warriors enforcing
his dream and promising to go to elbaf
on anna's lobby he frees oimu and kashi
from their bonds to the world government
perfectly reciting the giant's weapons
and techniques
[Music]
and after fighting side by side with
them once again he promises to meet them
in elbaf and finally he gains the
respect of hyrudeen on dressrosa who
declares him a god giving usop a very
high standing across multiple
generations among the giants of elbaf
the first lie i'd like to look at is
this one
[Music]
as i've discussed in my big one-piece
theory noland is actually one of the
most influential characters in the
entire story and a direct parallel to
roger himself outside of shandora noland
traveled the new world multiple times
and is worshipped by the tontara as well
and so usopp is tied to nolan through
the two statues he has one in shandora
and one in dressrosa and so i think it
would make a lot of sense for noland to
also have been to elbaf
one very popular idea is that usop will
defeat loki the current ruler of elbaf
which would fit usop's character arc
perfectly by the way a great reference
to david versus goliath a legend in
which the small david defeats the giant
goliath with a slingshot and i don't
find it too far-fetched to theorize that
usopp might find out about his
relationship to noland here as well if
this were true this could have some
major implications for usa it is quite
possible that noland just like roger was
one of the people who inherited joyboy's
will while failing to keep the promises
they made other characters that might
fall into this line are binks and nika
and the sun god was actually mentioned
the very first time during nolan's
flashback and as you know usopp has also
earned the status of a god and so if
this were true it would actually not be
luffy but usopp who would be the
inheritor of joyboy's will and setting
him up as the liberator of the giants
now i do still think that luffy is joy
boy but i did find this line of thought
very entertaining and even if usopp was
just a descendant of noland that would
already be pretty awesome in itself next
let's look at something that has been
hinted at a lot throughout the story
usopp getting congress hockey yes you've
heard me right i'm suggesting that the
usop our usopp might unlock what only
luffy and zorro have within the crew so
far so how does the ambition and will of
a king fit together with the king of
cowards well the very first clue is
already in the name usop has proclaimed
himself to be a powerful pirate captain
throughout the story and wants to become
a brave warrior of the sea in a way he
has these kingly ambitions in a more
literal sense than even luffy and zorro
as for willpower i already have
explained that to me usop has been brave
and strongly willed right from the start
the only thing holding us back really
are his self-doubts and his self-image
however this is slowly melting away usop
has already unlocked one type of haki
and that on the most extreme level we
have seen in the story so far picking
out the exact aura of a person miles
away from him so could there have been
any hints on the story similar to zorro
i believe that there is actually a ton
of foreshadowing for this usop has
actually lied about having conquerors
haki twice now once in this scene here
with the tantada
imam
and a second time during the raid on
onigishima additionally we have two
instances where usopp knocks out
powerful opponents by literally crushing
their will once with sugar
and once with perona
[Music]
both times we can see the characteristic
foaming mouth that is reserved for
someone knocked out by congress hockey
and as we know congress haki relates
very much to one's spirit and spiritual
presence as well as to one's ability to
affect the spirits of others and usob
was originally the only one able to
interact with the going mary's club
autumn so could this be another one of
his lies coming true once us reaches his
full potential in elbaf well i would lie
if i told you that i wouldn't absolutely
love it to round things up now that we
have a quite powerful usopp the last
theory i want to discuss has been
proposed by a reddit user called afric
who proposes that usopp might be the one
to bring an end to big mom's chase after
the straw hats shout out to her or him
or yeah we have already talked about
usop's relationship with the giants and
big mom shares this affinity with him
she has gone to great lengths to try and
include the giants into her peace
project and has been inspired by their
warrior spirit as well as you might have
noticed one of her main attacks is the
same giant technique used by dory and
brogi
[Music]
she actually uses it three times once on
whole cake island once on the live floor
in ongashima and once on the rooftop
with kaido and yet funnily enough the
only straw hat who hasn't experienced
this attack yet is usopp the man who
knows all of dory's and braggy's
techniques both of these character arcs
are on a direct collision course for
elbaf and yet their standing among the
giants couldn't be any more different
big mom who is seen as a force of
destruction and usopp who has been
heralded as a warrior and a god so usopp
might well be the only person to end the
feud between the straw hats and big mom
herself to solidify all this we're gonna
have some shenanigans with the chapter
numbers again you do know i love these
but this time instead of the word place
we'll just rearrange some of the numbers
because oda does love doing it for
instance take the first panels of
chapter
592 and 925
or 387 and 783
the chapters i want to look at here are
chapter 834 titled my dream that shows
big mom talking about her dream to unite
all the people and have the giants with
her as well as chapter 483 the end of
the dream which features lola out of all
people the daughter who ruined the
wedding with loki as we've already said
usop has the exact opposite standing
with the giants than big mom two sides
of the same coin so what happens if we
flip it chapter 438
in which usop chooses to return to the
crew instead of his dream of going to
elbaf what really blew my mind here is
that actually no matter which way you
rearrange these three numbers it always
has to do with characters thinking that
they have to give up their dreams 348 is
the chapter that robin chooses to go
with cp9 in order to protect the straw
hats giving up on her dream of learning
the history of the world and saul's last
wish of finding her friends 384 the
chapter where usopp tells oimu and kashi
the truth moments before they thought
they had to give up on their dreams of
seeing their captains ever again and
chapter 843 the chapter that sanji tells
luffy that he's leaving giving up on his
dream of the all-blue in order to
protect his friends so what do you think
will usopp say when he sees big mom's
attack will he say that he's actually
friends with dory and bragi that he's
fought side by side with the giants and
that he has hyrudine as his underling it
would sound like the biggest lie he's
ever told but turn out to be nothing but
the truth another character that is
strongly linked to elbaf and nordic
mythology is none other than shanks
himself if you want to know why i
strongly recommend you check out that
video right there oh it was there okay
right there right there it is right here
yeah